we are so excited to break some great
news this morning for the first time
ever
the national teacher of the year is from
nevada our own home state
and only on 8 news now juliana urdubay
joins us live from kermit booker
elementary school
near mlk and kerry good morning ms erda
bay and congratulations to you i know
you just got the news within the last
hour and
give us your first reaction
i'm just i was so elated so
proud and just i'm just overwhelmed with
joy
this has been an incredibly difficult
year for teachers for students for
parents
all across the country what has been
your biggest challenge of the last year
during the pandemic
this year has really just made us
realize how
important it is to maintain our
connections to each other
this is a team we absolutely have to
work together with families and partner
with them
and the students and just keep focused
on what is truly important
which is our students being well and
safe and taken care of
and um you know i just have to ask you
why do you think you stood out
among the four the three other finalists
who are
of course excellent teachers as well
what is it that
really that you that made you win what
do you think what
what do you do that's so incredible come
on give yourself a little pat on the
back
you deserve it i think one of the things
that i do
that makes me the teacher that i am and
that keeps me
trying to work harder every day is my
connection to their students to my
students and their families
i don't plan anything in my classroom
without considering their families i
want
my students to feel reflected in
everything that we do
and so when we built the garden we built
it with the help of the families
and the garden would have never existed
had it not been
for this wonderful huge giving community
coming together
to help us build a beautiful space for
our students
and and you teach through the garden and
your students call you miss earth
uh and you you teach with special
education
students uh primarily spanish speaking
students so
you have a real range of students and
and needs
with your students so tell us about the
challenges of that and
and has that made you a better teacher
absolutely it has my students teach me
every day that we all have strengths and
we all have possibilities
i like to think of my students with
learning and thinking differences
as students who just need a little bit
more encouragement to
show that absolutely they can learn they
can do the best that they can
and we're going to celebrate each little
milestone because we know how hard
they've worked it's all about how
teaching our students to have
the mindset that mistakes are okay that
learning is fun
and making sure that they understand
that what we're doing
is based on their strengths their
interests
i i love your mantra you say that
teachers should teach
and the school system should be joyous
and just
can you explain that
that's what i'm advocating for is a
joyous and just education for
every child by joyous i mean
that each student has a deep sense of
belonging at the school
because the school uplifts who they are
and by just
i mean that educators are working
collectively to design education spaces
where all students have what they need
to thrive
okay so we've got to talk about your
interview with gayle king
but your big surprise by the first lady
dr
jill biden i mean what was that like
talk about it oh as an educator
dr briden represents where we need to go
in education
she is a strong advocate it's been so
exciting to know that
our students will have access to two
years of preschool and then two years of
community college
if we truly believe that education is a
tool to transform for the better
then she's the right person leading it
she's fabulous
she has the heart of a teacher i nearly
fell to the ground when i saw her
i just i'm really appreciative
tell us what she said can you share a
little bit of what she said to you when
she came in
when i talked to her it's all a little
bit of a blur it's been a big morning
but what i kept hearing from her is we
and i think that captures how i feel
about today that it's not me
it's we it's all of us together it's we
and gail king is she a treasure or what
uh
what was that experience like
she was so kind and so warm and it was
just it was really fun
really fun well i know it's overwhelming
and i know
you're you're getting all kinds of
congratulatory messages and phone calls
and your kids are just gonna hug you all
day long
and uh we just can't tell you how
excited we are for you and how proud we
are
of you and to represent uh nevada ccsd
we're just uh we're so excited for you
so you will be an ambassador for
teachers
across the country do you have one
message that you want to share
as you spend the next year as teacher of
the year
i want to uplift the joyous and just
education and i also want to lead with a
heart full of gratitude
i'm so grateful for the families for all
the work they've done to help us get
through this year
i'm so grateful to teachers and the
entire school community
never have we realized how important
having healthy schools is and i just
want to make sure everybody knows that
the families
of our students are the heartbeat of
education so we have to keep our focus
on them well i'm sure they're very proud
of you so
thank you so much so are we your
students as we've heard
love you very very much as do the
teachers and educators
and i'm sure across america they'll get
to know you so thank you for
representing
all of us congratulations thank you so
much
you're so welcome enjoy you john
excellent stuff there congratulations to
juliana there and i guess
his first bell soon
for elementary school i think she has at
least another hour and a half yeah good
all right
enough maybe two hours